we're finally getting closer to the
truth about Donald Trump's alleged
affair with pornstar stormy Daniels and
the alleged hundred and thirty thirty
thousand dollar payoff that she received
let's go back to Donald Trump's attorney
Michael Cohen Michael Cohen has been
denying the entire story for a very long
time now but all of a sudden Michael
Cohen now admits yes stormy Daniels did
receive a hundred and thirty thousand
dollar payment but it came out of his
own pocket and personal bank account
says Michael Cohen now remember
Cohen originally denied that there were
payments he denied that there was an
affair he trumped out into public a
totally unbelievable note that stormy
Daniels had supposedly written saying oh
I never had an affair with Trump and was
never paid anything we could all see
through that note very very easily and
now all of a sudden Michael Cohen says
yes stormy Daniels was paid I paid her
personally and I was never reimbursed
now you might be hearing this story and
you're saying to yourself wait so they
got caught right they did it not really
the lies about the original story became
so untenable and so unbelievable that
this is the new position they've come up
with to try to defend Trump and you're
probably rightly saying wait David hold
on how is this denying the story and
defending Trump if Cohen is admitting
that he paid a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars how is admitting the
pornstar was paid a defensive trump and
the reason that it's a defensive trump
is that when Cohen says I paid her
personally they take Trump out of it and
you can see that this is what they're
doing from how they're answering
questions and from how Michael Cohen's
statement was written about this Michael
Cohen made a statement to the New York
Times about this where he said neither
the Trump Organization nor the Trump
campaign was a party to the transaction
with Miz Clifford that stormy Daniels
real name
and neither reimburse me for the payment
either directly or indirectly the
payment to Miz Clifford was lawful and
was not a campaign contribution or
campaign expenditure by anyone so under
this new explanation of what happened
they are saying this has nothing to do
with Trump fine the reports about stormy
Daniels getting a hundred and thirty K
are true but it has nothing to do with
Trump Trump wasn't involved it doesn't
relate to an affair and Trump didn't
know about it and in fact when you look
at how the follow-up questions went
Michael Cohen was asked did Trump know
that you made this payment he didn't
answer that question he was asked what
was the reason that you paid stormy
Daniels 130 thousand dollars he didn't
answer that one so they have come up
with this new obvious lie which lets
them say I guess with some plausible
deniability if you buy it that this has
nothing to do with Trump or the campaign
it was a private transaction private
person Michael Cohen paid private person
pornstar stormy Daniels who alleges that
she had an affair with Donald Trump one
hundred and thirty thousand dollars and
it has nothing to do with Trump
whatsoever and of course this only
raises more questions than it answers
right like now now we're really sure we
were on to something with this entire
thing I want to get me a lawyer like
Michael Cohen if he's willing to do that
I thirty thousand dollars out of his own
pocket generous that's not a small
amount of money is a very nice guy to be
paying her a hundred and thirty thousand
dollars and mostly what this suggests is
that the story all along about a Trump
affair and the payoff is the correct
story there are some contradictions
about the payment there are
investigations going on including by
common cause which say this was actually
campaign money that was used to pay off
stormy Daniels and that would absolutely
raise questions about campaign finance
law but this is all sort of a
smokescreen because for months remember
there was no payment now all of a sudden
there was a payment but it had nothing
to do with Donald Trump it just happens
to be a payment to the person who was
alleging an affair with Donald Trump
with very very specific details why did
he give her the money right that's the
question why did he give her the money
if the story isn't true I think as far
as Michael Cohen is concerned it's all
about avoiding any campaign finance
finally because this has happened before
I remember John Edwards back in 2008
paid someone off hush money
because he was having an affair with a
woman it was like a million dollars and
he was later indicted for it that's
right and it just doesn't pass the
common sense stats test right putting
all of this garbage aside the
misdirection why would a lawyer secretly
pay a porn star who happens to be
alleging an affair with his client right
that it does not pass the common sense
test and of course why admit this now
maybe to take attention away from the
Rob Porter wife beating security
clearance fiasco right before they
wanted to take away attention from the
porn star story now they've come up with
a way to make a partial admission on the
porn star story at a time when the focus
is on the entire chief of staff John
Kelly Rob Porter fiasco no other
president would be able to get away with
all this stuff I think about Barack
Obama or George Bush having an affair
yeah
there's no way the public would let them
go its way it's a scandal whack Amole
they're trying to whack one scandal and
then another and then another and it's
all becoming an insane gong show and I
hope you'll send me your thoughts I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman and the show is on
Twitter at David Pakman show today's
episode of the David Pakman show is made
possible in part by brilliant which is a
great online service that allows you to
master concepts in math science and
engineering by solving fun and
challenging problems and unlike other
learning sites when I'm using brilliant
I'm learning by working hands-on with
real-world scenarios and problems you
solve challenging puzzles that have been
designed by expert educators and
professionals from all over the world
they don't move too fast they don't move
too slowly they take you step-by-step
through the topics you're interested in
at your own pace and one of their
principles is effective learning is
active watching youtube videos which is
great by the way I encourage it and I do
it all the time that's a more passive
form of learning that gets you so far
that's when brilliant comes in and
you're watching you're learning not by
watching but by actually doing and you
can get started right now at brilliant
org slash David Pakman first 200 to
visit the website brilliant org slash
David Pakman we'll get 20% off an annual
premium membership but of course sign up
for free
at brilliant org slash David Pakman